if you want to refer to anything in the
offices report
can you please first clearly state the
relevant page number
and the paragraph number this is very
important so that we can all follow
whatever it is that you are referring to
is that clear everybody
is is that clear yes yes thank you
yes thank you thank you
yes we're fine to start chairman
all right good evening everybody welcome
to rochford district council's remote
audit committee meeting
and welcome to anybody watching on the
live stream
item agenda one apologies for absence
we've received apology from council in
newport
and councillor phil shaw
agenda item two
we have councillor julie gooding as
substitute for councillor phil shaw
are there any others no
agenda item three non-members attending
we have no non-members attending oh yes
you are
we do we have councillors smith and
councillor mrs mason
sorry okay so we've got
to account for smith and councillors
mason
kelsey mrs mason
councillor mrs bason
agenda item 4 minutes of the meeting
held on the 10th of march
2020. have we read them and are they
agreed members
agreed agreed agreed
agreed
german since i wasn't there i can't
uh give my vote for the minutes
no that that's that's fine i can't i
can't either i was
i wasn't there but uh so they're all
agreed yes
anybody not agreeing
all right agreed that
item number five to receive
declarations of interest are there any
declarations of interest
um chairman i have put my hand up for
this one
um yes it's just in relation to it's
mentioned in a couple of parts reports
about the
the grant of ten thousand pounds paid by
the council to various businesses
um one i am a shareholder in the company
which received the grant and also i act
for clients who also
received that grant it's a
it's a peculiarly in the sense that i
received it but it's it shouldn't affect
my
my voting or my participating in any
other parts of that
part of the agenda chairman can i also
uh declare a non-pecuniary interest
uh the very conservative club received
money
ten thousand pounds of which i am
chairman
thank you are there any
any others
thank you everybody
now before we actually start
can i please ask you to agree to a
change in the order of the items
on the agenda it would make sense to
deal with the annual
governance statement for 2019-20
which is currently item 10 before the
internal audit plan and charter 2021
which is currently item nine so that we
deal with
all the items relating to the 2019-20
financial year before considering items
within the current financial year
um i'll assume that you're in agreement
with this and they should click on the
raise hand icon
um it's just it just makes sense to deal
with one year
together and then the current year
together otherwise we'll get confused
so do we agree with that agreed
three agreed
no raised item agreed okay
right thank you thank you
agenda item six that is the external
auditor report certification of claims
and returns
annual report 2018 to 19.
um naomi lucas assistant director
resources will introduce the report
please naomi thank you
thank you chair um yes this
the purpose of this report is to um draw
your attention
to the certification of claims and
returns annual report
um for the financial year 2018-19
um so in accordance with um dwp
requirements
the council uh must appoint an external
auditor
to um perform um checks on the accuracy
of our housing benefits subsidy claim
um and the external auditor appointed
for
the financial year 2018-19 was bdo
um the report that is appended
to item six um summarizes the
results of that work and that they've
carried out
um and in summary
bgo um performed and certified
um our housing subsidy benefit claim
which had a total value of 15.6 million
um and now identified some small errors
totaling
235 pounds
and further to this um the department of
work and pensions
has extrapolated those findings across
the whole of the claim
and this has resulted in a further
adjustment of 5588 pounds
being clawed back from the council
however members will see that
that amount is not material when
compared to the overall value of the
claim
which as i said was 15.6 million pounds
uh in relation to this work um bgo
have um posed a scale fee variation
increase of
thousand seven hundred pounds compared
to their original fee level
um which all members will see um yeah is
is is more than the original fee that
was um uh proposed
that is as a result of the additional
testing work that they've had to carry
out for this um
the 1819 financial year compared to the
testing they were anticipating
when the fee was set which was um a
couple of years ago
which was based on a lower level of
testing and which was applicable at the
time
so the recommendation of the report is
just that it be noted
however if members do have any specific
questions i'm happy to
try and answer them thank you
i do have a question dog wait till
someone says my she's my hand up or do i
just come in um
sorry councilwoman i'm happy to answer
that is is um
chair are you happy for me to answer a
counsellor's question
councillor butcher's um
from the meeting yeah yeah she's frozen
currently
uh while councillor butcher is uh
apparently not able to communicate uh
yes
council ohio sorry would it be
appropriate to um
suspend the meeting while councillor mrs
butcher tries to
re-engage i'm just contacts you know
sonia sonia leslie
uh councillor leslie butchers assumes
just crashed she's trying to get back in
but she's happy for
a councillor dave merrick to carry on
the meeting
if david the councillor dave merrick
will would want to do this
okay that's fine okay um thank you
casper the um the question just really
is around um
on page 6.19
one of the recommendations is discussing
with a software provider to provide
bespoke reports um and i understand that
that's
being discussed at the moment according
to the next
um paragraph so i keep turning my head
because i've got one computer with the
things on there and
looking at that one um i just wondered
because it seems and also around the fee
there's there seems to be this perennial
problem that
additional audit work is required
because
the reports we're getting aren't quite
good enough and this seems to happen
year on year um i understand these
specific reports can be quite expensive
to
acquire from the software providers
because i think we've queried that
before
um i wanted to know how
how far down the line are we getting for
this report
is it just one report we need um
and is it is the problem because you
talked about sales so i assume we're
exporting reports to or the data to
excel at the moment is that the case
thank you um thank you councillor hoy
um so the um capita
um academy system that we use to
process all the information for the
housing benefit claims is
is a highly um complex um system and
we do routinely get upgrades and patches
and
and yeah different upgrades to the um
the system routinely to make sure it is
as up-to-date as as possible
um however there is um yeah any number
of um
sort of bespoke um reports that can um
can can be um designed and run
as the council sees fit for its
management information purposes
um so um yeah i
i believe that um that that this wasn't
a weakness that was particularly
identified
um before before the audit i think um
that
it's just been picked up um during
during the course of the audit that this
report um
didn't appear to quite be working as as
expected so
obviously we're taking remedial action
to try and ensure that that doesn't
happen again
um yeah we're always working to make
sure the system is as accurate and
up-to-date as possible
however um i think yeah there's always
the um chance that there's an
ordinary anomaly um that's that's picked
up just because of the complexity of the
information and the number of reports
that can be run out
of the system um yeah so i think that's
probably
all i could say really on that point so
have we
asked have we yet approached them for
this report that we are
according to the management response we
are doing
and have we got a cost for it yet i
believe we have
um approached um capital about the
report i don't have a cost estimate
to um hands but i can certainly find out
what that cost is
um but as i say it's not unusual we we
do um
often and get
a request or upgrade the system or or or
run bespoke report so it's not
it's not unusual in that in that respect
but i can certainly try and find out
if we've had a quote for that particular
report
can that be supplied to members of the
committee please chairman
not the report i don't think we want
that but the the fact that we have
got the information and requested the
report i think the chairman is not back
with us
oh yes thank you
german yes councillor
us but sparing
thank you chairman the uh it's only a
small question i assume this increase
uh the scale of personal money's
being paid for the additional work
required it comes across as some sort of
statutory level does it is there a sort
of a
set cost per hour or is it just a a
random figure that they
that the authors request
um yeah thanks thank you council
sparring um
so in the case of the um housing benefit
audit we
uh we've opted out of um
the kind of national framework agreement
and we
um have entered into joint procurement
um
with basildon um to actually procure
uh the um the the audit services of bgo
and so at that point
they um submitted a um an estimate of of
of the fee level over the
the course of of that um contract term
so we had an indicative fee at the start
for each of those
um three three years i believe um
so they based that estimate as i say on
the sort of um
level of and errors that were found in
the 50 i think it's believed the 15 16
audit which um for whatever reason was
was lower in that year um the nature of
the housing benefit
um checking is that
if an error is found that then
necessitates um a sort of hundred
percent sample check of of of the audit
so it
it requires a significant amount more
work and then that has to be
re-performed to the following year so
um any errors you know from one year to
the next sort of get carried forward and
then have to have um additional checking
so um in terms of um how then
they cost that um additional work
we have had a detailed breakdown from
bgo of how they've arrived at their
uh of that fee and we have been through
that with um with them in
in a detail essentially um they
place an additional charge for each um
sort of set of testing that they have to
to re-perform
um so the fee level that they've
subsequently arrived at is is based on
the number of additional
testing sets that they've had to they've
had to do so
um in that respect we can't really sort
of argue or
negotiate the fee massively because it
is based on the error level that they
they found albeit as i've said the error
level overall is not massively material
in terms of the overall value of the
claim okay thank you chairman
uh councillor carter
thank you chad naomi thank you for uh
for your comments on that
could you um just ask us um what has
been done to prevent um or what will you
be doing to prevent
any uh future problems that might occur
in this
place okay thank you councillor carter
um yeah that's a difficult one and when
we do obviously get asked every year um
i um obviously where particular errors
have been identified we put in place an
action plan and set out in the report of
how we would try to address those in
future and ensure those
those errors don't happen again um
the reason i say it's a difficult one is
purely because the volume
and the volume of claims that we have to
process every year is so
high and the value of those claims are
so high that inevitably
is you know human human error this is
never going to be 100 accurate um
and i think every council is in that
same situation where
you know the the volume of errors is is
low but
um yeah as i say there's always probably
going to just be a few so obviously if
if there was systemic issues that we're
having the same errors year on year or
there's a particular
um officer that was you know routinely
making errors obviously we try and pick
that up and address that
but i i do think it's very difficult to
say that we're ever going to get 100
accuracy and i don't believe that any
other
councils have managed to get to sort of
100 accurate accuracy as much as we
would
obviously strive to do that
thank you
councillor mrs mason
uh thank you mrs chairman i think you're
back
aren't you um yeah just a couple of
quick
questions if i may um i know
note that uh the 5588
is not considered material um could the
section 151 officer or whoever
is appropriate advise at what level you
would consider
the errors to be of a material nature
and of concern
yes thank you council mrs mason so um
the the housing subsidy audit is
slightly different from the
main audit which we'll speak to later in
the in the meeting in that
um the auditors at the outset of the
audit don't set a level of materiality
as
as such um because and as i say they
have to actually um
check um they have to report on any
errors
so any any error no matter how small
will be reported and picked up
whereas um yeah in our main audit there
is a level of materiality
below which the auditors wouldn't
necessarily sort of um
feel obliged to to report that um i
suppose my assessment of
what i what i mean by materiality is in
the context as i say of 15.6
million so i i think most committee
members would agree that
five thousand or six thousand pounds um
yeah as a proportion of the overall
claim value of 15.6 million
um is not material in that context thank
you
you haven't answered the question madam
chairman if i can come back the question
was
at what level would you consider
this material um i i accept what you're
saying about the 5588 pound
in the scheme of things is a relatively
small amount
however um i'm just
curious as to when concerns would be
raised
and when you would consider it material
well thank you mr mason i have tried to
answer the question as best i can as
i say that we don't actually set a
materiality threshold so
um i can't give you a number um
above which i would consider it material
all i can consider is the actual error
rate that's been identified
and i don't believe that in this case
that i would classify that as material
but
i haven't got a threshold as such above
which i would
then sort of have a cut-off point and if
that makes sense
uh thank you madam chairman if i may
i've got one more question
um which hopefully will be able to
be answered if not tonight at the later
stage
um do you know if other councils use the
same
system and are we all paying for the
same
reports um
you know is is this a problem overall or
is it a problem specific to rdc
i think from what you've been saying
it's probably a general problem
thank you councilman mason um
so a number of authorities do use the
capital academy system
and we are not alone in that um offhand
i know that morden also uses that system
there are there's a sort of three or
four main revenues and benefits systems
that are used across
local authorities um so no system is
is perfect um and each
authority will have tailored and you
know bespoke to their system
as as they feel fit to a degree
obviously the core set of reports are
probably quite standardized
but if there's a specific um sort of
issue with a particular report
and it's likely that that would be
affecting all councils that use that
system equally and generally
in that case um the system provider
capital would
would sort of provide a patch or update
which then gets applied to all
local authority systems equally
thank you thank you madam chairman
uh councillor carter
i'm sorry chair i've already asked a
question i
don't know what's happened my hand it's
um
it goes up and then it comes down and it
goes up and it comes down again so um
there isn't
anything i need to ask thank you thank
you
councillor high
sorry chairman i was going to ask a
question but it's just been asked thank
you
okay thank you so no no further
questions
no so there's
a recommendation um
paragraph 71 on page 6.2
and that recommendation is that the
certification of claims and returns and
your report
2018 to 19 be noted is that
noted members agreed
agreed
all right thank you anyone who doesn't
agree just put their hand up
right that's been noted okay agenda item
7 the 2019-20
external audit audit plan and updates
and um naomi lucas
uh will introduce this report as well
please
thank you chair so um
yeah as as a report sets out um
this is formally presenting um the
council's um
annual audit plan and addendum um
as um submitted by our external auditor
ey
um to cover the audit of the 2019-20
financial statements
um and also to provide an update on the
status of this
um the audit this this year um we do
have with us tonight
um chloe um weaver who's the audit
manager for the audit so
i will bring her in in a minute to give
um
a progress update in terms of the the
audit work for this year
but i just like to remind um members
that the um the normal time scales that
we'd be working to in a financial year
um have been delayed um
or deferred slightly in light of the
covered 19 situation
so ordinarily we would publish our draft
accounts by the 31st of may
and we don't have them audited by the
end of july
however um legislation has been passed
to allow
um us to um uh defer the publication of
the accounts
until um the 31st of august
um and um get them audited by the 30th
of november
um we have um published our draft
accounts on the 25th of june
so we've met that statutory deadline um
in terms of the
the council's um publication of the
accounts um
the audit work is still ongoing although
substantively complete and we didn't
actually
delay the planned audit work um that was
scheduled in prior to covered 19
so that work is it is is um
primarily done and but chloe will give
an update on that in
in a minute um
so appended to the report is the um
audit plan as i said which was present
um which was submitted
uh before the coven 19 situation and
there's a second
appendix which um sets out the updates
to the audit plan in light of code 19.
um so i have previously circulated those
two members
um because i've yeah i felt it was
appropriate obviously that you had
the opportunity to see those before the
audit work commenced
um so i as the audit work as i said is
now
um substantively done i'm not proposing
to go through the audit plan in any
great detail
um unless any members have any specific
um
questions i'll assume they are they have
been read and noted
already um but again i'm sure that um
chloe would be willing to answer any
questions that you might have
on those um
so the reports
at paragraph four also sets out
the proposed fee level for for this
audit
for um the 2019-20 financial year
um this hasn't been formally agreed
yet but as the report sets out ey are
proposing um uh
a variation of 23 181 pounds
um to the original proposed scale fee
level
um in light of the additional work
um that they will have to carry out
which is detailed in
in that addendum um that isn't the
actual final fee level at this stage
because they haven't completed their
work and there may be additional work
still required
in respect of code with 19 and
potentially other factors but that is
their proposed
um scale fee increase
um so yeah the recommendation of the
of the report is is just that the plan
and end and be noted but at this
um point i would hand over to chloe to
give an update on the status of the
audit um
work so far if that's okay thank you
chair
thank you naomi so as
naomi said i'm pleased to say that we
have substantially completed
our audit of the financial statements
for the year ended 31st of march 20
in accordance with our audit plan and
audit plan addendum
that you will have seen in the papers
as naomi mentioned we did commence our
audit in june
in line with our agreed time scales that
we initially
set out in our audit plan so there were
no delays
in light of covered 19 to the audit
timing
and i'm very pleased to say that the
audit has progressed smoothly and
efficiently
despite the challenging remote working
environment that we've had to
cope with and is not usual for the way
we would normally conduct an audit
there are some key elements of work
where we have been unable to conclude
at this point in time and these include
the pensions assurance so in line with
other years we place assurance on the
work
completed by the auditor of essex
pension fund
and they are still completing their
audit of essex pension fund at the
moment so we're unable to conclude the
work
in that area we're also awaiting one
investment confirmation from lloyd's
bank who we write
to directly for confirmation and then we
are also progressing work
on going concern in our audit plan
addendum we have highlighted going
concern as an additional area of focus
for us
in light of covid19 and its impact on
public sector funding
and that's an approach we're taking
across all our local authority audits
this year at the moment management have
provided
going concerned disclosures within the
financial statements
and they've also provided us with a
supporting going concern
assessment and evidence to allow us to
complete that work and we're currently
reviewing this information
but at this stage in time unable to
conclude on that work
through the course of our audit so far
we've identified only one audit
adjustment
totaling 135 130 000 pounds
and this is just a reclassification
between income
and expenditure as a result of
accounting for a housing benefit
recharge
and i just want to highlight that
there's no impact on the net expenditure
within the cies
as a result of that item it is just the
classification between income and
expenditure
we have noticed some minor disclosure
adjustments
but none that we would consider
significant enough to warrant the
attention of the audit committee
at this point in time we have also
largely completed our vfm work in
accordance with
our audit plan and our work has evidence
that the council has put in place proper
arrangements to secure value for money
and we expect to issue an unqualified
vfm conclusion
we are expecting to receive the
assurance from the essex pension fund
auditor in september
which will allow us to conclude the work
on the financial statements
so we therefore plan to present our
audit results report at the next audit
committee
thank you
councillor hi you have a question
thank you i'm sorry today um just
generally it's not it's sort of i've got
loads of little notes written down on
this
one but i suppose it really comes around
a covered most of it because obviously
that's
although kobe doesn't actually affect
the accounts too much because most of
it's occurred afterwards
a lot of it will reflect on the con
continuing delivery of the asset program
for instance
and around value for money and around
the value of the properties potentially
and things like this which is mentioned
in the appendix
which i'll keep losing because keep
dodging to and fro
um so so it's really
the the questions are very detailed but
i think i'll try to summarize them so i
don't take up
forever with it it's around how
although you've got some things here
clearly some work needs to be done on
how
you're going to test the value the value
for money for
moving forward and the going concern
moving forward in particularly
there's also money coming into the
council
which i believe is supposed to match the
excess
costs which have been incurred i think
now
naomi will collect correct me well it's
about 970 000
give or take that we've received which
is supposed to match and i know
that we do a report that naomi sends us
every month i think it is
to central government about those
figures so it's really testing around
have you what testing developed around
that because but that's really moving
forward although some of those costs
would have
been incurred in this period and also
i just have concerns about the asset
values and asset values moving forward
really particularly although you've said
value for money
you've done that i just how do you do
value for money when
the asset program may have been
the values may have been changed by
covid and what may happen in the
property market
really that's what the question is it's
i'm trying to summarize it rather than
give loads of different little points
except help is a question you could
answer or not
or two questions thank you
yes thank you council ahoy so in terms
of
vfm so we specifically look at the
arrangements
in year so we would only be looking at
the arrangements up to the 31st
of march 20 now obviously covid did hit
quite late in march so the impact on our
vfm conclusion from a 1920 perspective
is actually quite small so it's only
really reflecting the sort of last week
of march so that's not to say we haven't
done anything
we have looked at how the council
immediately responded
to covid19 um but that's sort of the the
extent of our work from a vfm
perspective as you say the the bigger
impact
is rightly so going to be the following
year so 2021
so it's it's likely that our vfm risks
will reflect
um kobit 19 for the 2021
financial year and i guess the second
part of your question was around
asset values so from
the financial statements accounts audit
the asset values included within the
balance sheet
are subject to some uncertainty as a
result of covid19 so the valuers that
valued the
the assets in the financial statements
have at this point in time disclosed an
uncertainty over those values as at the
31st of march
so we have done some we have done some
additional work
to get ourselves assurance that those
values are materially correct
but we have requested that the council
does disclose the material uncertainty
that the valuer has included within
their reports and it is likely that our
opinion will include
an emphasis of mata paragraph that would
divert the reader's attention to this
disclosure but
we have got the assurance we require so
our opinion wouldn't be modified in
respect of that matter
and the final bit was about government
support that just under a million pounds
we've received
yeah so i believe that the most of that
money was received
after the year end so in early april so
it doesn't actually
impact on our audit of the financial
statements i believe the amount that was
received before year end was not
material from our perspective
and as you say the costs incurred in the
1920 year
were weren't what we consider to be
material
but again it could be that we will
reflect that in our risks for
for the following year okay thank you
thank you so um
our risks are really for the following
year not for
not for the year that we're looking at
at the moment
so that no further questions
um on paragraph 7.1 on page 7.2
there's one recommendation that the
annual audit plan and addendum for
2019-20 be noted
is that noted members
noted thank you
so the next item is item eight internal
audit annual report
um mike porter chief audit executive
will introduce this report
thank you thank you chair
i can ask members to refer to um page
8.1
of this report the purpose of the report
itself is to
provide the chief audience executive's
annual opinion
on the overall adequacy and
effectiveness of the council's framework
of governance
risk management and internal control in
operation
during 2019-20
the opinion is largely derived from a
programmer work
undertaken by the council's internal
auditors
and that program of work is basically
formulated
into an annual audit plan the annual
audit plan for 2019-20
was actually approved by this committee
in may of 2019
and during 2019-20 the committee has
received a number of progress updates
on delivery of the audit plan and the
results of individual audits carried out
during the course of the year
appendix 1 to this report some rises
that work
in turn awarded completely during the
course of the year
and since uh the committee last met in
march 2020
a total of five further audit
engagements have been completed
and two of those were rated as good and
three adequate
in total we've um actually
achieved 20 audit reviews during the
course of the year
only one of those audit reviews resulted
in a limited assurance opinion
if the other 19 audit reviews either
received an adequate or good rating
in addition to this um audit work we
also undertook a further four
light touch audit reviews
so as i said the the my opinion for the
year is largely based on the work we
undertook during the course of the year
so i'm satisfied that we undertook
sufficient work during the course of the
year
to enable me to enable me to draw an
opinion on the council's
arrangements for governance risk
management internal control
that is not just to say that we have
looked at everything during the course
of the year
um our audit plan is largely risk-based
but we do also look at the council's key
financial assistance
we are not able to look at everything
during the course of the year
so that's why our risk our audit plans
largely risk-based so we identify
what are the major risks concerning the
council and we will look at those during
the course of the year
so based on the 20 audit reviews
undertaken during the course of the year
um i am providing an adequate assurance
opinion on the council's arrangements
for risk management internal control
and governance in operation during the
course of the year and that these
practices generally called it proper
practice of are fundamentally sound
although there are some opportunities to
improve these arrangements
in addition i would like members to if i
can ask members
to turn to page 8.3 of this report
um i'd like to briefly talk about the
counter fraud activity
that is undertaken by the council the
council is actually responsible
for investigating all non-benefit fraud
and much of this work is undertaken by
the council's compliance officer
that actually sits in refs and ben's
benefits sorry
and as you can see from this report some
significant casual savings that's been
achieved during
the course of the year um 146 000 pounds
has been achieved it's a direct result
of identifying
unbuilt properties and withdrawal of
council tax discounts or exemptions that
no longer apply
further we have identified cash flow
savings
in the region of 652 000 pounds in
relation to
business properties that were previously
not on the rating list
um further to these additional um
savings we've identified um overpayment
housing benefit
um to to the value of 36 000 pounds
so as we can see from that that report
um we achieved some significant cash
flow savings over the course of the year
lastly i'd like to talk about um the
effectiveness of internal audit um we
are required
to undertake an annual self-assessment
of our performance during the course of
the year
and this is done by self-assessment
checklist
um there is nothing for me to comment on
in relation to this checklist
we've performed the audits in relation
to the public sector internal audit
standards
and i have no concerns in relation to
the work carried out during the course
of the year
in addition to the annual
assessment we undertake ourselves we are
required of an
external assessment every five years
and this was undertaken in january 2019
which found that the internal audit team
largely conformed with the public sector
internal audit standards
i'm quite happy to take any questions in
relation to my report
any questions i've got a question from
councillor high
uh thank you chairman yeah thank you for
the report um
it's just a couple of questions really
one is on page eight point
um one five around assets management
um 8.15 um there are
some outstanding issues there it's not
the insurance level is adequate but the
risk area is that there are audit
recommendations arising from 2017
18 and 2018-19 audit work that have not
yet been implemented
it just seems it just seems a long time
not to have implemented them is there a
reason why they haven't been
implemented that's the first question
thank you council like can i pass that
over to jim
uh thank you um the key ones
uh am i there
am i there yes we can hear you
the key recommendations that are not
done they relate specifically to
the uh
the asset register um it's proven to be
a very complex piece of work and it is
progressing
um and we have it has been reviewed to
sort of link into the
uh other reviews that are going on and
should be in place by the end of this
financial year
i just feel like ever since i've been a
counselor we've been reviewing the asset
register
yes suppose in some ways it's a long
piece you're forever doing it i suppose
but it just seems
we never seem to get there uh yes
absolutely right counselor the situation
is we have
different people using different bits of
register and what we don't
we think we've got all the we've got all
the bits of assets we need we just
haven't got them in one place and that's
what we're trying to develop
all right
okay yeah thank you um the other one
this is where my um
notes are letting me down i've got page
8.8
because i'm aware is something
i find it which has been reported to us
before so it's been through us
um but i'm talking around emergency
planning on page 8.8
which was reported to the audit
committee on the 10th of march 2020
[Music]
it was marked as good i would and
hindsight is a very good thing
i'd hope we might re-look at that at
some point because i don't think
our response was good i think it would
be below
good that's a in some ways it could be
subjective but it's also
something that i'm aware that the
managing director has sent around submit
um some requests for members to say what
well what when poorly what what worked
what didn't work as well
but i just feel that maybe the emergency
planning
i don't think we i know other members
will disagree but i don't think we
responded as we responded or were
capable of responding if we had a good
emergency plan
that's all so it's something just a so
wonder how we looked at it to check that
it was a good emergency plan
whether or not we'd ever actually tried
to enact some of the things in the
emergency plan
and it just makes me cautious
about accepting other
audit reports in the future
maybe perhaps i or other members
maybe we should be questioning more when
things are good
as well as when they are adequate or
limited
i'm not sure it's a question you can
answer apart from the fact will you be
looking at
that again is that going to come up
again emergency planning in the internal
audit
yes cancer that uh we thought that uh
this will be an ideal opportunity to
look at it putting it into practice so
we have included in this audit plan
with regards to what we did last time it
was it was very much a theoretic
exercise
uh based on what what do we think we
covered
and the organizations were working with
so from a sort of a planning viewpoint
that it appeared to be well considered
obviously
proof has been the pudding when the
situations happen
yeah under there is hindsight yeah it's
very easy with hindsight
although the review this is interesting
because the review committee did also
pick up about this and i just wondered
this is one of those committees where or
one of those subjects where two
committees
tend look at it sometimes and i just
wonder how if there could be more
liaison between two committees sometimes
over things like this
to save one duplication of work and two
try to feed off each other sometimes
um that that's just an observation for
that one um
the second one is eight point two two
and eight point two three which is round
up i see
and security there were just a couple of
comments i wanted to
pick up um on the report particularly on
page 8.23
um in the on page 8.23
um on the second paragraph of the
executive summary
towards the bottom it says where's the
third line up from the bottom paragraph
members and staff now use
0.365 system on updated council issued
equipment
um
this is not necessarily the case i'm
aware that
staff will use it on their own personal
equipment
i use office 365
on my own personal computer i'm aware of
other members
doing the same um
so i'm not sure i'm not sure how
that affects what i mean the statement
is wrong factually
because it's used elsewhere i'm not sure
how that affects what the
audit was trying to do i'm not a
technical expert on
i t it's just a question that the
statement there is wrong as far as i'm
concerned
if it's right as far as ict and your
audit of it that's fine i just need an
explanation
and then further down um the second
paragraph on the bottom
um starting to the last word of the
second line it says liaison with the ict
ict team identified 85 to be deleted hey
these were
um users many of them
so these are users who didn't need to be
users on the ict system i understand it
um can i just confirm
it says they've been identified to being
deleted have they been deleted i think
it's the question
thank you they're the two questions
there okay the first one uh
i'll have to look into that other one
the the first question because uh my
i was under the opinion that all all
staff and members have been issued
realized with
capital basic it kit which they should
be using
to keep the integrity of the system so
that's something
that's not what i've been told i was
told i could use it on my personal
computer i mean i'm
this what i'm doing now is on a council
issued
toshiba
sorry yeah we could yes
you can use office 365 to access
your emails uh and
items such as teams but you shouldn't
but from
officer viewpoint you shouldn't be able
to get into any of the operating systems
without going through the portal
okay this is where we as members don't
right
have the same access as officers
presumably
yeah yeah like when you talk about the
academy system for reversing benefits
only certain people can have those
and that can only be accessed through
the portal through the
the network we have and that yes
possibly a confusion in uh
terminology
okay and the second point um the users
us were mainly um
staff who had not been deleted are
various it's
external i.t staff who hadn't had reason
to
uh the system who have been left on
i've been assured by the ict team that
the 85 people that are identified have
been deleted
okay thank you
thank you um councillor shaw
thank you councillor butcher uh just jim
just let you know
uh council i think shaw and myself do
not use
cows uh council issued equipment because
we
we had it it never worked when we gave
it back
and we now use our own ipads
so just let you know the shores council
shaws do not use uh um
council issued equipment just for on the
record
thank you thank you thank you councillor
and i believe
uh council williams doesn't use the one
either
thank you i'll take that up with the it
team just to pretend
thank you thank you and councillor i i i
know
thank you for pronouncing that correctly
leslie councillor butcher
uh jim um as a former portfolio holder
for enterprise
uh i can confirm that uh um
there are a number of uh councillors
within the chamber who do not
actually use the council supplied
equipment and there is a
a register which actually details
exactly
who is using the council
equipment and who doesn't
chair if i may just come in there i do
believe that it's council policy that
remembers that they can use their own
devices if they
so wish but i think the point of issue
is about which systems they can
or can't access without the appropriate
security and i think that's the issue
we'll take back and just
check with the ict team but i don't
believe there is an issue per se with
members using their own devices
that is council policy thank you
thank you we have no further questions
so
at paragraph 12 on page 8.5
there's one recommendation that the
chief
audit executive's opinion on the overall
adequacy and
effectiveness of the council systems of
governance
risk management and internal control be
noted
is that noted members noti chairman
merry teacher chairman thank you
right we're going now to item
10 because of
our readjustment and item 10 is the
annual governance statement for 2019
20 and jim cavani principal auditor will
introduce the report
please
thank you chair um this is to introduce
the
annual government statement which is a
statement which will form part of the
financial accounts so how well we
believe that we have been
governing ourselves throughout the year
this pulls together
uh audit work uh external reports
self-assessments by uh heads of service
or
assistant directors um if i could just
put remember to this structure of the
the report section one on 10.7
is an introduction to what the corporate
governance is about
section 2 on page 10.9 is the
preparation of the ags which is the
basis for
doing it statutory officers reports
the chief field executive report and an
overview
of covid and how we dealt with it
section three on page 10.13
is uh the compliance of the
local code of corporate governance which
lead council has adopted since 2017
uh section four on page 10 20.28
is how we address issues that we
identified going forward into
2000 1920
and section 5 on page 10.30
are matters that we've addressed from
this year's review that need to be
looked at going forward
um i think that's the introduction
are there any questions
no questions sorry i'll get my hand up
um it's not a question as such it's um
it is a question it's i suppose it's
this is one of those reports where i
always have great difficulty with it
because i often quite describe some of
the things
in there but that will be because i'm
coming from a
minority group perspective rather than
the administration
and i accept that it's an
administration's report firstly
um however i just felt that
the peer review is mentioned in here
and and i'll be fair he's mentioning
paragraph 10
10 point something 10.34 i think
on page 10.34 um
however i think there the
i think the although it's mentioned it
it's glossed over more than the report
itself
should be i think because it said there
were fundamental issues around review
committee fundamental issues around the
mtfs
and i know the mtfs is mentioned in 10
on page 10.26
and it does mention about the peer
review but not the fact that it
should be forecasting for further
forward it's
mentioned an established mtfs and budget
setting processes in place
principal c however the peer review
brought up the fact that the mtfs
should be more detailed and and better
looking forward than than we have so
just so we've got an established one
is really underplaying what the peer
review said in my opinion
um we put lots of figures in
on page 10.18 about
social media and our apparent reach on
social media
but yeah but again we it's we don't
really
we're talking about just their corporate
has 5 000 followers corporate
facebook has 3 000 likes an instagram
500 followers
but we're not we that's all we're saying
we're just talking about people who
follow me not
saying about the reach of those and i
think the problem is we're not measuring
the reach to put in there and i think
the report be much better if we went
a bit deeper down and said that we are
reaching more clickbacks from
these are we we managed to help five
people from these we just we we're just
giving basic figures
um
and i mean i'll leave it there this is
the problem i could go on and on and on
about it
where it underplays things and just
gives these out i think the
i'm not trying to be critical with it
i'm trying to say that i think we could
be much
better with it if we actually gave a bit
more
detail than in here but i know it's a it
shouldn't be too detailed but trying to
to say not necessarily say that
everything's great but maybe say look
the peer review did identify this and
we've got an established mtfs
but based after the peer review we're
going to work on it and make it better
this is the sort of thing i think we
should be putting in here rather than
saying everything is great now
or everything's established it's fine i
know it's not literally what we're all
saying but i just
this is my problem with the statement as
it stands and and probably every year i
have the same issue
you're probably bored will be saying it
now and i'll leave it there
i i don't think you'll be changing
anything from it but it's just
if moving forward perhaps we could have
just be a bit more
informative i think is what i'll be
trying to say thank you
thank you
thank you uh councillor carter
no i'm sorry i'm not i haven't got my
hand up sorry
okay councillor mason
i know it's picky but i do prefer
council mrs mason
um i must endorse what counselor
mr hoy has said we
get these reports we gloss over them
and we're not really proactive with
putting things right
we it seems to be a little pat on the
head or we've done okay
could do better we'll perhaps
um we should be a little bit more
proactive
i'll just say that the peer review
was some considerable time ago with no
no
real um activity to
rectify the thoughts in there appears to
have been taken
and i'm sure the same will happen with
other issues
but it sometimes these issues although
they appear criticisms they're not
criticisms or they should be taken
as a constructive or if you like a
critical friend
and when you have that information it's
to help you
i think we need to take it on board the
information that's given to us
and use utilize it rather than
find it under done thank you
[Music]
thank you got any
answers to that um jimin kevin
i totally understand the uh
nature of these uh critic constructive
criticism
um i'll try to bear that in practically
try and bear that in mind a bit going
forward next year
okay thank you i may chair as well just
add something there
please sorry
apologies chair i was just going to add
a comment if that's okay
yes yes it's gone um i i was just going
to say in respect of the
the peer review that um
that work hasn't been um sort of
shoved onto the carpet so to speak um i
mean it is slightly unfortunate in terms
of the timing that it reported at the
back end of last year
and we did um subsequently develop an
action plan which is referred to in the
annual governance statement
um i think to be fair that it is noted
in the annual government's statement as
an outstanding action
um but i i believe that covid um
has obviously had an impact not just in
terms of our ability to
progress some of those actions um so
inevitably we have had to focus on core
work over the past few months and
perhaps not
um had as much capacity to to deal with
some of the actions arising out of that
action plan
but also i believe that we will have to
revisit some of
the um actions and outcomes of of that
plan in light of things that have
changed as a result of code as well
so that that work is um still um being
progressed
um and as one of the council has alluded
to there is um
an action from review committee as well
to report
on the actions of um um the the peer
review action plan
um and obviously that will be one of the
sources of assurance that
um both internal and i'm sure external
audit will
look to um in order to form their
opinions um on our overall governance as
well so
um i just want to give some assurance to
members that that work is still ongoing
but inevitably there has been a
little bit of a pause over the past um
few months in respect of that work
thank you chair thank you um i've got a
further quest
question from uh councillor high
i think counselor mrs mason was before
me chairman all right councillor mrs
mason
yeah i'd just like to come back on that
i appreciate the officer's defense of
her situation
but we have had in the past few months
with the
um that's affected all of us quite
severely i would say
a regular group meetings the managing
director has assured us that work has
been able to carry on as normal
it seems that we're getting a
contradiction here if we carry if work
has been able to carry on as normal
then that's the mrs mason can i just
interrupt you a minute i think
you've got your television on yes i have
you turn it down
now turn it down please i'll set it down
but i'll shut the door
thank you
sorry i didn't mean to interrupt you but
it's um interfering
i've learned to blank it out sorry
um i i am just
concerned that these things
seem to take an
murder counselor inaudible thank you
thank you councillor hi you're saying
i'm not going to talk about the peer
review
in the same way as uh council mrs mason
what it was i'd
yes i understand it's in the report and
it is mentioned in the report which is
good
and i'm not trying to complain about
that i'm just saying i think it should
be more embedded around each of the
items as well
such as the mtfs when we mention the
mtfs perhaps we should be thinking about
what the peer review said and mentioning
that in the same place as well
so it's much more understandable and
readable but by everybody
they can see that the mtafs
when they read about the mtfs they can
see there's something about it in the
peer review
and how to improve it even more that's
all it's only it's just something
looking forward i think
if i may just come back again on that um
chair um yeah i i accept i accept that
constructive then
sort of criticism counselor thank you
and as i say i think
part of the issue is that we haven't
actually had the opportunity to
um actually look at and address in
detail
the recommendations of the peer review
so that piece of work still
um still more work does need to be done
on that and um
i'm anticipating that um further detail
will be um included in in next year's
report so um as i said earlier it's not
that work isn't intended to be done but
it hasn't been really completed
um and just to
come back to councillor mrs mason's um
point i
i don't believe that we've been
inconsistent in terms of what work we
have
or haven't been able to do we've
inevitably had to
focus on our core processes um
more during this time and we've kept the
core business of the
council operating over this difficult
period
however um almost by definition
the actions of the peer review are
relate to new work and new projects and
new activity that has to be taken
forward and i suppose that
that's the sort of work that has been
slightly put on pause during this
period while we focus on keeping the
cooperations of the council running so
thank you thank you
there's no further questions
so a paragraph eight one on pages 10.2
and 10.3
there are two recommendations
number one that the annual governance
statement for 2019-20 be endorsed and
referred to the managing director
and leader of the council for signature
number two that authorities delegated to
the chairman of the audit committee
to endorse the changes to the annual
government statement
following review by the council's
external auditors
can we vote on both recommendations
together members um
i will assume you are in agreement to
vote on both unless you click on you
raise your hand now
sorry chairman i'll be voting
differently on them
so you want them separately
unless i can just say i don't mind just
saying how i voted on
one and two as we do but if you've got
to go through the pitch goal
i'm sorry i'll vote differently that's
all
okay thank you hi um
in that case we'll vote on
the first recommendation that the annual
government statement
for 2019 be endorsed and refer to the
managing director and leader of the
council for signature
uh voting's done by a roll call of names
when sonia calls out your name please
indicate if you
wish to have a recorded vote and then
whether you are voting
for or against the recommendation or if
you wish to abstain
is that clear
yes
counselor mrs butcher
uh i don't need a recorded vote and i'm
voting for the recommendation
thanks to mrs carter
thank you chair i'm abstaining
councilman
i will be voting for the motion
and i don't need a recorded vote thank
you chairman
councilman boy i'm a stating
thank you chairman answer your honor
no recorded vote and i'll be uh m4
councillor lucas gill no to a recorded
vote and
voting for
translameric no
and four
councillor milne no recorded vote
and i'm voting for
counselor mrs shaw no recorded vote and
i'm voting for
councillor sparing no recorded vote and
voting for
right the result of that is eight four
and two abstentions so that is um
agreed right
number two is that authority is
delegated to the chairman of the audit
committee
to endorse the changes to the annual
government statement for in review by
the council external auditors
and we'll go through the voting same way
answer mrs butcher
uh no recorded vote and four
councillor mrs carter
thank you yes
answer mrs good no recorded vote
and four thank you chairperson
councillor hoy no recorded voting for
the motion thank you chair
cancel your honor no recorder vote and
full demotion chairman
answer lucas gill no recorded vote
and four are you doing
counsellor merrick oh and four
councilor milne no recorded vote and
ford emotion
council mrs shaw no recorded vote on
four
cancer sparing no recorded vote and four
yes thank you members uh that vote was
unanimous
so that has been carried
agenda item nine
internal audit plan and charter for 2020
21 and the chief audit executive
mike porter will introduce this report
thank
[Music]
um the you will sense my annual um my
audit plan for 2021
and internal audit charter the charter
itself is essentially a formal document
that defines internal what is purpose
authority responsibility and position
within the organization
it also sets out the nature of our
services
um how internal would it all support the
organization
in achieving its objectives um the audit
plan itself
builds upon the previous year's internal
audit work
and it's also based on the corporate
risks facing the council
it also links to the business plan for
20 20 23
in addition to looking at risk the major
risk
facing the council we also undertake
audits in relation to the key financial
systems
these keys financial systems are
important to the organization in terms
of the controlled environment they
provide
and it's something that external audit
look to look to rely on
um it is likely that the plan will
actually need
revision during the course of the year
as the um risk environment in relation
to curve holds
and we continually assess what support
we can give to the organization
um i think it's fair to say we won't
ex or won't look or deliver a normal
audit plan for 2021
as kobit 19 um risk unfold
um we will continue to um keep the audit
plan
under review during the course of the
year and any changes to the audit plan
itself will be reported to committee
um the plan itself
um is set out um at
9.5 and lists all the audits we all can
undertake during the course of the year
and as i said earlier in my previous
agenda item
this work is used to actually formulate
my um annual audit opinion at year end
um in relation to the plan
the public sector internal audit stand
is a state that
it is not for members to direct the
audit plan
but be satisfied that work will
enable them to draw sufficient
assurances from the work we undertake
and the plan itself relates to the
the key risk of the council so members
actually need to be happy
that the audit plan will give them
sufficient assurances
in relation to the council's
arrangements for internal control risk
management and governance
um i'm quite happy to take any questions
in relation to the the item
all right thank you um councillor hi
thank you chairman um the first question
will be on page 9.3 around resources i'm
aware of the last
audit committee that we had i believe
taken on her in the process process of
taking on another audit person
can it be confirmed that
was the case and that they are still
with us
and that we are in in normal
circumstances would be
we'd be able to complete the audit
program i understand it isn't normal and
you've already
referred to that that was that the first
question
thank you councillor uh yes we we didn't
undertake um and put him
in post another member of staff um and
her name is becky and she's been in post
for
uh a little lower a year um what's
happened since then is that
she's now on maternity leave or starting
maternity
leave in june and so the audit plans
based on
the resources of one individual but the
plan itself is also supported by
baseline council so the plan is
basically put together based on known
resources
so we knew becky was going to leave be
leaving us in june
to basically go on maternity leave but
we also realized that um
the plan is also supported by auditors
from my own council basin
council so the the plan is based around
known risks and we
we look at the risk involved and then
apply how much how much resource we need
to actually
undertake those pieces of work and
where necessary the plan as i say will
be supported by a baseline council in
terms of um resources provided by
by myself okay thank you
that's cleared that one up i was a bit
concerned it was
just because we couldn't cope still but
it's planned that's fine
um the next question is
um oh it's a difficult question um page
9.6
you're looking at emergency planning and
business continuity
i've already brought up one of these um
i'm sure
so that's been looked at again i think i
probably had the answers on
that one um
the concern is it's been sort of
answered but the concern is
around you said
emergency planning was good before it in
my opinion it wasn't
so going by what you said that we need
to have confidence in what you're doing
will will be adequate i i just wonder
what you'll be doing to make me have
more faith in the process on that one
okay thank you councillor i suppose when
we previously looked at it
i suppose it's more around theory
because we hadn't put it into practice
but now given we have code with 19 we've
had the chance to actually test
our arrangements so we would look at
actually what we did and what we could
do better so i think it's like
it'll be more of a lessons learned
approach so we would look at we did
um whether you feel that was appropriate
or not
so i think i think it will be very much
a lessons learned approaches you
what did we do well what could we do
better and then
and then building that back into the
process in terms of improving our
arrangement
so i think we'll have the opportunity to
now test our arrangements
and we can now comment on actually how
they worked out in practice
rather than just a theory approach
because in the past i mean
you can test them to the degree but
there's no substitute for
actual arrangements
yeah well they um understand the staff
of
um fed back as well on what went well
what didn't go well and
members have as well is that something
that is made available to you as well
to look at yeah we will in relation to
the audit we will approach
all parties concerned and asked to ask
um individuals how they felt it went and
we can seek um
reviews or comments from from everyone
across the board
in terms of how they felt it went yeah
is this
being done as a
as an early thing to do or relating to
i'm just saying this because obviously
this is still with us and it may we may
have to
act on your findings sooner rather than
later it's what i'm thinking
if if we have to
if there are more problems low i mean
maybe on a local level there might be a
lot down on a local level for instance
and
people may not return to our offices in
relation to the business continuity
as we would hope so i'm wondering how
quickly you're looking into doing this
work
i think this is a piece of work we will
do in in the next
um two to three months it's a key piece
of work to understand actually
what we could do because i think you as
you rightfully say kobit 19 is now going
to be with us
for some time so i think we need to look
at actually
what we did what went well what didn't
go well and then put some of those
lessons learned into practice
because i think we'll probably will
again need to reduce it later in the
year
as the whole risk environment unfolds so
i think it is
a crucial bit of work that needs to be
done early on and
we will sort of prioritize that piece of
work to make sure that it is delivered
over the next two to three months
okay thank you the um final question
you'll be glad to know is
also on page 9.6 this is around cyber
security and invest in investigations of
critical information breaches
um does your audit work
involve looking at whether or not we're
insured for it or could be insured for
it to reduce
our financial exposure
i think that's a very good point i i
think it's something we need to consider
yes
so we we can include that in terms of
the scope of audit
to to understand how we mitigate the
risks and what are our insurance
arrangements in relation to cyber
security yes
all right thank you that was the last
question
thank you all right there
no further questions
so at paragraph 8.1 on page 9.3
there's one recommendation that the
proposed audit plan and chart of
2021 be approved and voting will be
the same way as before so if you want to
um against the recommendation or if you
wish to abstain
and if you want a recorded vote thank
you
that's the mrs butcher
no recorded vote and for
counselor mrs carter
thank you no recorded vote and four
cancer mrs gooding no recorded vote and
four thank you chairman
rajoy no recorded vote and four chairman
thank you
cancel your honor no recorded vote and
four
councillor lucas girl
no recorded vote and four
cancer mrs shaw no recorded vote and
four
houses sparing
no and four
right thank you members
that looks as if that isn't
unanimous again so the motion has been
carried
now we go on to agenda item 11
audit progress report 2021
mike porter again will introduce this
report
thank you very much chair thank you
this is my first progress report for
2021
and listed the work we've undertaken in
the first quarter of the year
it's fair to comment that um usually the
first quarter of the year
quite a bit the work revolves around
tidying up the work from the previous
year
um and making sure all the final audit
reports they've issued in relation to
the previous year
and making sure all the recommendations
are captured from our order reports so
a fair amount of work in the early
months of the new year are around
finishing off the work from the previous
year tidying up water final reports
um that's not to say we haven't
undertaken any work
and before um becky um went off from
maternity leave
we have undertaken a number of audits
and these are identified
at 11.5 to this report
so we've actually achieved four audit
reviews
um in the first three months of the year
and these are
relate to um parameter input building
the user permissions
in relation to academy safeguarding
use of permissions in relation
dimensions and we also did a light
touch um audit in relation to
procurement
we undertook a review of procurement in
the previous financial year
and there were some identified control
issues
so we did a light touch review looking
at um low level expenditure
and what we we found is that in relation
to low level expenditure
um where quotes are required for um
items at this level quote quotes weren't
always obtained
um so we want to look at basically we
contract procedure rules in relation to
procurement
and looking at the um where when we
require quotes in relation to this this
level of expenditure
um it was in relation to um other work
we undertaken in the first three months
of the year
jim's been really busy um in doing
initial testing in relation to the
housing benefit subsidy
this work supports the work of external
audit
um so jim's been really busy in
undertaking this work as i say
and it's a major piece of work that um
external would it rely on
i'm quite happy to take any questions
there any questions
i don't have anybody down for a question
so at paragraph 71 on
page 11.2 there are three
recommendations
one that the update on delivering the
2021 plan be noted
two that the conclusions and results
from completed audit
engagements in appendices two and three
be noted
and three that the updated status of
audit recommendations in appendix four
be noted
is that noted members no teacher
noted chair
all right thank you agenda
item 12 review of the council's risk
management framework
and corporate risk register uh naomi
lucas will introduce this please thank
you
thank you chair um yes
um as the chair said this report is to
present
the updated corporate risk register for
the council
um for consideration and approval um
the whole corporate risk register is
included at appendix
a and sets out all the key risks that
the council
faces and together with control measures
in place to mitigate those risks
and an assessment of whether um we feel
the risk
remains high medium or low risk in terms
of
the likelihood and the impact of those
risks
um generally speaking we only review
half of the risks um
every six months and in the other half
the the second six months of the year
um in light of all the changes and risks
that the council is facing at the moment
we felt it was appropriate to do a
refresh of the entire risk register for
this um committee
so all of the risks have been reviewed
by the risk owners
for for this committee meeting um
so at um page 12.2
and paragraph 4.4 there's a summary of
all the changes
um or um amendments that have been made
to
um the the risks um uh so they're all
set out
um for your um consideration there
um and further a paragraph um
5.1 on page 12.3
um we just note that
um while um obviously covid and also
um our exit from the um the eu
are um significant issues that the
council is facing
um because they are actually sort of
known issues that the council is
um in the process of um dealing with and
addressing they're not risks as such
they aren't they are being dealt with
so um in terms of those um factors
they are addressed where there's
particular risks um in relation to
specific areas of the risk register
so for example um on the finance mtfs
risk
um we've updated that in light of the
covid um
uh risks we we've faced so
that they have been um updated and
addressed but they're not
um presented as sort of specific risks
in their own rights
but they have as i say all risks have
been um reviewed in light of
in light of the current situation um
so i think the report is relatively
self-explanatory
um and the recommendation is just to
note the report
but um as ever i'm happy to try and
answer any specific questions
um that members might have thank you
yes council ohio you have a question
yeah thank you
chairman um there's two questions really
the first one is a general one about
page
2 basically 12 point no it's not 12.23
it's west sort of 12.22 2.23
um the corporate risk map
i when were these last reviewed i've
gotta fit in the head that i've
i've seen them been reviewed i just feel
that their
their jury review i think we look at
financial for instance on page 12.23
that's the top
top there um a critical
a3 is two hundred thousand to one
million
um catastrophic is one million to ten
billion and ten
ten million well one million would be
catastrophic
maybe i i just feel that the the size of
these
the financial ones that and some of the
other subjective points made could do
with a good review
at the moment i feel that the particular
financial parameters for what's critical
and what's catastrophic and what's
marginal they i think they could do do
with a review i don't know if
these are standard ones but i think for
accounts in our size
they're not necessarily appropriate in
my view
and also that's the same if you go
further down
um where we've where we might have um
the legal ones for instance that
are these the appropriate measures we
should be taking are these written in
the right way they
they are subjective i understand that um
and it's
easy dealing with figures rather than
something which is a bit subjective
but i wonder when when these life been
reviewed what they're based on and
whether they're do a review
thank you that's the first question
thank you councillor hi
um so in answer to your question there
was a complete review of the risk
framework um i believe just about a year
year ago now um and um leadership team
did a
full review of the framework um in
conjunction with some
external advice from one of our insurers
and
zurich and i believe that subsequently
that report was presented to audit
committee for their approval and
sign-offs i believe that was about a
year ago um
we we um yeah we will review it
regularly so
um we can always um go back as you say
and i think some of the
measures as you say are fairly
subjective in their nature so there's
probably not
um a right or wrong answer as such but i
um yeah it was reviewed and signed off
by audit committee relatively recently
we can check back on the exact committee
day
thank you sorry i'll still mute you
there thank you
for that we've got the other points we
we now seem to have
residual risk we now seem to have three
at high i think one of them which is 3b
as
gen generally being fairly high anyway
which i think is around the food isn't
it that's the health and safety
incident um
no the food was three aces health and
safety which we got as high
and also then we've got item 9
which is sustainable failure to ensure
financial sustainability
for the council which we talk about a
lot and also 10 inability
recruit retain development managed staff
hi um what are we
doing to mitigate these risks
down from high
okay well
i mean i've seen the principal controls
and actions before and
i think number 10 particularly we always
seem to have this
this problem there's a lot of um
controls and actions we're doing
but i think we've been doing those for
quite a long time for instance
and they don't seem to be making a lot
of difference at the moment
okay thanks thank you councillor um just
to go to the staffing one first i mean
this is something we have had
further discussions with with our hr
lead and and with the managing director
um i think the the status of the
residual risk still remaining high
just isn't reflective of the inherent
risk of us as a
as a small council and as you're aware
we have a relatively you know
a small complement of staff we're a
small council and we have to compete in
a um
you know competitive job market and then
the reality is that if one or two key
members of staff
um leave for whatever reason that does
place us in a
slightly vulnerable position in terms of
um
having um yeah the the um
uh sort of backup and in terms of our
offices to fill
to fill that so like i think it's it's
difficult just to
know uh yeah what
we can do to sort of manage that risk um
to bring it down to medium but it is
something that has been actively
considered um obviously we've got
recruitment and retention
and policies in place we've got we've
got our people plan in place so we do
everything we can
to uh yeah recruit and retain good
officers but
as i say it's an inherent risk that as a
small council we're always a bit
vulnerable in terms of if people
were to leave for whatever reason um in
terms of the ntfs
risk um i mean that is one i have um
sort of deliberately um reclassified for
this time
um in particular in light of some of the
the risks we're
we are facing as a council financially
um in particular
in light of some of the covered um uh
risks that you've alluded to
earlier um so again i think it's um
in relation to the inherent on
instability
um of local government finance
generally and and as much as as a
council
we can respond and react and try and put
in place control measures to
to react to that the the the reality is
that
um that there's bigger external
influences outside of our control not
least
um the local government funding
settlement from local
from central government and the fair
funding review that was
that has been postponed for a number of
years now means that you know our our
financial system
our financial um yeah system is quite
inherently sort of un
unstable and it's difficult um as i said
with the staffing one
to put in place controls that will bring
that
that down significantly so i mean i i
accept what you're saying but i think
it's
it's a combination of of local factors
and things that are within our control
and that interplay with
the external environment and things that
are outside of our direct influence
so do we expect those three or those i
suppose nine and ten in particular
um to stay with the residual risk that
high at the moment under this system
we we don't expect to be able to manage
those down at all
particularly well the um thank you
council
and the i mean the starting one has been
high and remains high and as i say
i would expect that probably to remain
high because there's there's not
a huge amount we can do to control our
risk
um other than as i said to try and you
know keep retaining
recruit good officers um the financial
one as i've said that's only just been
put up to high
and i would keep watching brief on that
obviously if we get some
firm answers both from central
government and the covid situation
sort of plays out in relatively short
order it maybe we can revisit that and
and reassess whether that should be
higher going forward but for the moment
i would
um judge that that is obviously one of
the major risks facing the council so i
believe that high is the right the right
rating for that
okay thank you thank you
uh counselor carter
thank you chair uh naomi could you
answer please um
who actually sets the risks please
thank you councillor carter so um i mean
the risk register is
owned by the leadership team um we have
a risk and performance officer who
supports in that process
but essentially it's jointly owned by
the the leadership team but each
risk is assigned an individual owner who
is responsible for
updating and refreshing that but um yeah
obviously if
an individual ad felt it was appropriate
to add a new risk we are
um always open to to revisiting the risk
register
thank you
so we have no further questions
nobody else wants to speak so
there's one recommendation a paragraph
11.1 on page 12.4
and that is the content of the corporate
risk register for 2021
2020 2021 be approved
voting will be at the same uh way as
before
when sonia calls out your name indicate
if you wish to have a recorded vote
and whether you're voting for or against
mrs butcher no i recorded vote
and four thank you sonya answer mrs
carter
thank you no recorded vote for
cancer mrs gooding no recorded vote
and four thank you chairperson thanks
for watching
i now recorded voting for thank you
chairman
councillor you are now no recorded vote
and four
hands to lucas girl no recorded vote
and four cancer merrick
no and four councillor milne
no recorded vote and four
council mrs shaw no recorded vote and
four
council sparing no recorded voter end
for
right i think once again that is
unanimous
so that motion has been carried
so that concludes the meeting tonight
thank you so much for everybody for your
for attending and
all your questions it's been um
it was a long meeting we had a lot on on
tonight but we got through this quite
well so thank you very much
so the meeting now is closed at 21.09
good night chairman good night everyone